[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les émeutes contre les violences
policières aux états unis elles
s'étendent à la plupart des grandes
villes américaines 5 au cinquième nuit
consécutive de violences
le corps d'un homme a été retrouvé tôt
ce matin près d'une voiture brûlée à
minneapolis
donald trump accuse l'extrême gauche et
félicite les soldats de la garde
nationale pour leur maintien de l'ordre
dans cette ville du nord de l'amérique
des manifestations également à londres
on va le voir
le président américain qui va reporter
le sommet du g7 et l'élargir à d'autres
pays donald trump considère les pays
habituellement dépassé
peu représentatif de ce qui se passe
dans le monde le chef de la maison
blanche veut convier la russie la corée
du sud l'australie et l'inde à cet
automne le sommet initiale était prévue
en juin la chancelière allemande a déjà
décliné l'invitation pour raisons
sanitaires
alors que le nombre de patients en
réanimation continue de baisser en
france les bars et les restaurants
s'apprête à rouvrir mardi mais
uniquement en terrasse en région
parisienne l'application controversée
stocks au vide sera également disponible
après demain tout être un e circuleront
à plein à partir de la mi juin a annoncé
le secrétaire d'état aux transports ce
dimanche
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche
nouvelle journée de colère en amérique
contre les violences policières
la violence qui gagne est maintenant
tout le pays ou presque d or qui
s'étendent maintenant à los angeles
washington ou bien new york où une
voiture de police a foncé sur des
manifestants à minneapolis la ville où
est décédé un afro-américain lundi le
corps d'un homme a été retrouvé tôt ce
matin près d'une voiture brûlée
retour en images sur les émeutes de ces
dernières heures regarder
à
je suis fatigué que mes hommes noirs et
mes femmes noires soit abattu tué par le
nypd
j'en ai assez j'ai trois hommes - chez
moi je suis fatigué je suis fatigué mes
frères et soeurs noires se font tirer
dessus sont tués sans raison je suis
fatigué
non
honnêtement je pense que nous devrions
réformer la police la police existe
depuis trop longtemps
tout ce qu'elle fait c'est de la
corruption elles causent plus de
problèmes qu'elles nous aident
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
au coeur du bien
j'étais toujours en première ligne je
prenais des photos j'essayais juste de
faire un reportage sur ce qui se passe
ici et tiraient des grenades en
caoutchouc j'ai dû recevoir comme quatre
fois sur la tête et plusieurs fois sur
les gens
monsieur
raconter leurs histoires dites leur nom
à tous il y a eu trop de morts georges
floyd c'est la cerise sur le gâteau il y
a trop d'histoires et nous en avons
assez de toutes ces histoires raconter
leur histoire
dites leur nom nous en avons assez de
cette injustice dans nos systèmes dans
toutes nos systèmes et alors que la
garde nationale a été déployé dans une
douzaine d'états américains le
gouverneur du minnesota annonce la
mobilisation de 13 mille militaires
supplémentaires dans un tweet le
président américain a tenu à saluer ces
militaires qui maintiennent l'ordre
depuis six jours maintenant dans la
ville du nord des états unis
son rival joe biden candidat démocrate à
la maison blanche a appelé à l'arrêt des
violences regarder mon administration a
ouvert une enquête pour violation des
droits civiques et j'ai demandé au
procureur général et au ministère de la
justice de l'accélérer je comprends la
douleur que ressentent les gens nous
soutenons le droit des manifestants
pacifiques et nous entendons leur appel
mais ce que nous voyons maintenant dans
les rues de nos villes n'a rien à voir
avec la justice ou la paix la mémoire de
georges floyd et déshonoré par les
émeutiers
les billards et des anarchistes à la
violence le vandalisme sont dirigés par
les antifas et d'autres groupes radicaux
de gauche qui terrorise les innocents
détruisent des emplois nuisent aux
entreprises et incendient des bâtiments
manifester contre une telle brutalité
est un droit et une nécessité c'est une
réaction éminemment américaine mais
mettre le feu à des villes et la
destruction gratuite ne l'est pas la
violence qui met en danger des vies ne
l'est pas le président américain qui
vient de faire savoir via un tweet que
le mouvement antifa et est maintenant
classé parmi les organisations
terroristes aux états unis voyez à
présent l'analyse de gérald olivier
spécialiste des états unis
et auteur du livre sur la route de la
maison blanche il ya trois éléments
importants
le premier c'est que le scénario
malheureusement aux états unis il est
assez classique est connu c'est une
brutalité policière
une victime noire des deux
manifestations les manifestations qui
dégénèrent en émeutes et les émeutes qui
font tache d'huile d'une ville à l'autre
c'est à ça qu'on assiste depuis cinq
jours maintenant vous avez deux éléments
nouveaux le premier c'est que ces
émeutes se déroule dans le contexte du
coc vite 19 et d'une pandémie qui a
entraîné un arrêt total de l'économie
avec pour un certain nombre de gens une
perte de revenus père de travail père de
revenus et une société situation
extrêmement instable voire anxiogène qui
pourraient non pas justifiée mais
expliquer certains comportements et puis
l'autre élément nouveau c'est la
présence de ce qu'on appelle les antifas
les antifas ce sont des mouvements
radicaux violents qui sont là pour faire
de la casse et qui dès qu'il y à la
moindre étincelle quelque part va se
précipitent pour tourner cette étincelle
en grand feu ces mouvements ont
d'ailleurs été dénoncée par le garde des
sceaux monsieur williams bar parce que
ce sont des émeutiers professionnels et
lorsqu'on garde en dehors de minneapolis
là où s'est déroulé l'incident qui a
provoqué tout cela la mort de ce
monsieur georges claude on s'aperçoit
que ce sont pas du tout des mouvances
noir que les émeutes ne sont pas
limitées aux quartiers noirs
on a plutôt ces émeutiers professionnels
qui viennent et qui détruisent pour le
plaisir de détruire et ça c'est un
phénomène assez nouveau également des
manifestations également devant
l'ambassade des états unis à londres des
milliers de protestataires ont investi
vous le voyez le quartier de trafalgar
square ce dimanche ils ont aussi défilé
dans les environs du parlement
britannique à westminster plusieurs
marches se sont aussi tenues en europe
ainsi qu'au canada
écoutez les manifestants britannique
nous voyons depuis des centaines
d'années que les noirs et les gens de
couleur sont absolument maltraités et
tués dans les rues
et ça ne fait qu'empirer nous en avons
assez et s'ils ne veulent pas écouter
nous allons crier de plus en plus fort
et nous n'allons pas arrêter tant que
quelque chose ne sera pas fait nous en
avons assez
ces gens en ont assez les temps de faire
quelques changements le président
américain va reporter le sommet du g7 et
l'élargir à d'autres pays donald trump
qui considèrent les pays habituels comme
dépassé ce sont ses mots et peu
représentatif de ce qui se passe dans le
monde
le chef de la maison blanche veut ainsi
convié la russie qui en avait été exclu
la corée du sud l'australie et l'inde
cet automne le sommet initiale était
prévue en juin
la chancelière allemande a déjà décliné
l'invitation pour raisons sanitaires
boyer l'analyse de karine bêcher goal of
qu au professeur invité à l'université
d'état de moscou la russie est toujours
prête à participer aux négociations
internationales d'autant plus qu'elle
est une puissance internationale qu'elle
compte sur la scène internationale comme
on l'a vu depuis 2015
lorsqu'elle est revenue avec la
possibilité de faire revenir la crimée
lors de la crise provoquée en ukraine
avec la russie avec la syrie pardon ou
la russie a permis de mettre en danger
la domination de l'état islamique dans
la région et ainsi de contrer le jeu des
groupes atlantiste donc la russie est
une puissance internationale
a priori elle est toujours ouverte au
dialogue le problème ne vient pas
d'apporter les salles de classe
washington qui a mis fin cette semaine
aux dérogations des pays européens qui
ont des relations avec l'iran malgré les
sanctions contre téhéran liées au
programme nucléaire certains pays
avaient bénéficié de dérogation spéciale
elles seront levés dans deux mois ont
averti les états unis
elle permettait par exemple à des
entreprises européennes russe ou
chinoise de travailler sur certains sur
certains sites nucléaires en iran
oui la réaction du nouveau président du
parlement acquérir mazet
le onzième parlement considère la lutte
contre l'arrogance comme un intérêt à la
fois idéal et stratégiques et considère
que négocier et jouer l'apaisement avec
les états unis
axe de l'arrogance globale serait
inutile et nuisible
notre stratégie face à l'amérique
terroriste et de finir de venger le sang
du martyr soleimani elle a commencé avec
la taxe sur la base d' al assad et la
rupture de la puissance vie d'américaine
puisqu'elle n'a pas pu répondre à l'iran
et se terminera par l'expulsion total de
l'armée terroristes de l'amérique de
notre région et voyez à présent les
réactions de la france de l'allemagne et
de la grande-bretagne à l'arête ces
dérogations
l'union européenne a fait part de ses
regrets et via un communiqué nous
regrettons profondément la décision des
états unis de mettre fin aux trois
exemption portant sur des projets
nucléaires clé du pg assez ces projets
servent les intérêts de tous en matière
de non-prolifération et offre à la
communauté internationale des garanties
concernant la nature exclusivement
pacifique et sur des activités
nucléaires de l'iran
nous consultons nos partenaires afin
d'évaluer les conséquences de cette
décision prise par les états unis les
états unis qui maintiennent également un
bras de fer avec la chine notamment sur
la péninsule de hong kong et sur le
retrait de leur contribution à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé un
face à face aux allures de nouvelle
guerre froide selon les propres termes
employés par pékin
lille à fan's donald trump franchi un
nouveau cap dans son bras de fer avec la
chine
cette fois ci le locataire de la maison
blanche je remets tout simplement en
cause le statut spécial qui lie les
états unis à hong kong
il menace de supprimer les privilèges
commerciaux de l'ancienne colonie
britannique
une annonce qui vient compléter une
série de mesures de rétorsion contre
pékin en réponse d'après le président
américain
à la décision de la chine d'imposer une
nouvelle loi sécuritaire à hong kong
donald trump qui annonce également des
sanctions contre les officiels chinois
et hong kong est qu'il accuse d'avoir
directement ou indirectement contribué à
réduire l'autonomie de hong kong
djelic c'est une tragédie pour le peuple
de hong kong pour le peuple de la chine
et pour le monde entier
dans la foulée donald trump annonce la
fin de la participation américaine à
l'om s l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
la raison invoquée l'organisation serait
trop indulgente avec la chine dans la
gestion de la crise du coronavirus nous
avons détaillé les réformes que le ms
devait engager directement avec la chine
mais l'organisation a refusé à cause de
ce refus d'engager des réformes
nous retirons immédiatement de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
allons nous tourner vers d'autres
organisations publiques dans le monde
qui méritent notre aide
avec le retrait américain l'organisation
risque de perdre entre 15 et 20% de son
budget cette décision peut flatter une
base électorale
opposé à l'impôt et au multilatéralisme
mais elle pourrait se révéler contre
productive sur le plan de la sécurité
sanitaire mondiale et enfin dernière
annonçait la mise en place de
restrictions d'entrée sur le territoire
américain pour les étudiants et les
chercheurs chinois pendant des années la
chine s'est livré à des activités
d'espionnage illicites pour voler nos
secrets aujourd'hui je vais prendre des
mesures pour protéger nos universités
les plus importantes et suspendre
l'entrée de certains ressortissants
chinois que nous avons identifié comme
un risque potentiel de sécurité la
concomitance des attaques tous azimuts
contre la chine
avec le calendrier électoral américain
n'a pas échappé à l'opposition démocrate
le président veut détourner l'attention
accordée à ces manquements vers la chine
donc il fait ce qu'il faut pour de
mauvaises raisons alors que les
élections présidentielles américaines
approchent à grands pas
le président sortant est actuellement
très fragilisé il doit affronter non
seulement les critiques sur sa gestion
de la crise sanitaire
une crise économique sans précédent mais
aussi des tensions raciales rani des ces
derniers jours dans tout le pays alors
que le nombre de patients en réanimation
continue de baisser en france les bars
et les restaurants s'apprête à rouvrir
mardi mais uniquement aux terrasses en
région parisienne l'application
controversé stop covit sera également
disponible
après demain tous les trains eux
circuleront à plein à partir de la mi
juin c'est ce qu'a annoncé aujourd'hui
le secrétaire d'état aux transports
l'ancien commissaire européen pierre
moscovici sera nommé mercredi premier
président de la cour des comptes par
emmanuel macron l'ancien ministre des
finances socialiste tout le quinquennat
de françois hollande succède ainsi à
didier migaud à 62 ans il fait son
retour en france après avoir été
commissaire européen aux affaires
économiques
voyez les réactions à sa nomination
nommé moscovici premier président de la
cour des comptes et un une honte pour la
france 2 le choix d'un courtisan
incapables qui dira oui à tout 3 la
prolongation de la casse des services
publics en france 4 une marque du
transfert de souveraineté à l'union
européenne
5 tout ça à la fois tiens moscovici la
personne qui n'a pas récupéré 2,2
milliards d'euros que la société
générale doit rendre depuis l' affaire
kerviel chargée de s'assurer du bon
emploi de l'argent public et d'en
informer les citoyens et citoyennes
j'ai comme un doute que l'on passe un
accord avec wauquiez pour les
municipales à lyon
moscovici nommé à la cour des comptes
après avoir parlé de populisme
mainstream au sujet de macron voilà ce
que produit le soi-disant nouveau monde
nous avons moins de deux ans pour
tourner la page quand tu veux que rien
ne se sache tu nommes un camarade à la
tête de la cour des comptes et marche
pour le droit au logement a été organisé
aujourd'hui à paris
et manifestants qui ont parcouru la
capitale et traverser des lieux
symboliques de la crise du logement
il demande au gouvernement une action
immédiate actions pour aider les
personnes qui ne pourront pas payer leur
loyer
en cette troisième fin de mois de la
crise sanitaire écoutez à ce sujet
justement le porte parole du dal ces
descentes ten de milliers de locataires
mais aussi d'accès dans la propriété qui
vont se retrouver en difficulté qui vont
être convoqués devant les tribunaux le
ballet des u6 a déjà commencé les
commandements de payer commencent à
tomber et c'est donc nous on alerte on
dit là attention au gouvernement et vous
avez mis 110 milliards d'euros dans
l'économie vous pouvez bien mettre
quelques milliards d'euros pour aider
les locataires à payer leur loyer
prendre des mesures aussi de baisse des
loyers d'augmentation des apl c'est et
suspensions également des procédures
d'expulsion c'est-à-dire un moratoire
des loyers comme l'ont fait de nombreux
pays européens l'espagne le portugal
l'italie la suisse l'allemagne
voilà c'est des pays qui sont
normalement enfin on voit bien et pays
du sud et du nord
bon bah ils ont dit oui on va aider les
habitants à rester chez eux
on va pas leur faire payer la crise
sanitaire
cet après midi près de 500 personnes ont
également défilé à
montigny-lès-cormeilles c'est en région
parisienne un hommage à un jeune homme
de 18 ans qui est mort mercredi soir
percuté par un train alors qu'il roulait
sur une mini-moto une fausse rumeur a
aussitôt attribué à la police la
responsabilité de ce décès qui est des
violences urbaines se sont déclenchés
dans la foulée voyez la réaction du père
de la victime
c'est un gentil garçon se passe bien
c'est mon fils et en même temps elle est
bien entourée de ses jeunes loups là
vous avez vu tous ces gens l'agréable
quitte à bord de l'énergie on est des
gens fait ils ont paru tout en sachant
que réel de jeu dire de ce qu'ils ont
dit des premiers temps et est vrai enfin
c'était faut juste y avait de 4,7
quelques personnes
voilà on a en face à nancy mais
l'essentiel on revient monfils personnel
ici il est parti s'amuser après le
travail
dieu a fait que voilà personnes au
royaume-uni de nouvelles restrictions
vont être levé demain les réunions de 6
personnes à l'extérieur sont de nouveau
autorisées tout comme la réouverture
partielle des écoles maternelle et
primaire certains commerces comme les
concessionnaires automobiles pourrait
aussi accueillir à des clients voyez les
des décisions qui ont été jugée
prématurée par des épidémiologistes
britannique à côté du combat
nationaliste
il s'agit d'un ensemble de diverses
mesures qui vont potentiellement
permettre au virus de revenir et de
commencer à se propager plus largement
et l'autre point dont vous devez être
conscient c'est que ce que nous faisons
et avec quoi je suis d'accord ce que
nous faisons c'est d'essayer de
remplacer ces mesures générales par une
approche beaucoup plus ciblé des mesures
de traçage ou au lieu de mesures
générales de confinement de toute la
population
vous mettez en confinement pour quelques
semaines les gens qui sont des plus à
risque c'est donc ça l'idée mais ce
système de traçage n'a été lancée que je
dis nous ne pouvons donc pas être
certains que cela fonctionne déjà
efficacement et pourtant nous allons
tout de même effectué ces changements
donc je pense que c'est plutôt dangereux
même si nous n'avons pas un deuxième pic
et que nous gardons simplement le taux
de contamination à ce niveau cela
entraînera encore un grand nombre
d'infections est un grand nombre de
personnes mourront l'ins un état
d'urgence jusqu'au 21 juin en espagne
mais madrid continue aussi d'alléger les
restrictions
si la réouverture des frontières est
prévue pour le mois de juillet certains
touristes notamment allemands français
ou bien scandinave pourrait bien n'être
autorisé à a passé les pyrénées dès la
mi juin
une nécessité pour l'espagne compte
beaucoup sur la saison estivale pour
relancer son économie
voyez ce reportage à barcelone signe
éclaire nico les 17 hectares du parc
guell à barcelone voit défiler en temps
normal pas moins de 3 millions de
visiteurs chaque année
selon les chiffres de 2010 est autorisé
à
promenez depuis un mois les barcelonais
se réapproprie petit à petit le deuxième
site touristique le plus visité de la
ville une année noire pour le secteur
mais cette absence de visiteurs ravis
tout de même certains riverains qui re
découvre les trésors de leur patrimoine
cela fait dix ans que je n'étais pas
venu pourquoi parce que d'habitude c'est
rempli de touristes et il y à beaucoup
de monde
alors maintenant on profite qui n'est
pas de tourisme on peut venir et en
profiter d'une autre manière
quand il y à des touristes et les bancs
sont tellement plein tellement remplie
de gens qu'on ne peut même pas voir la
vue derrière les bancs alors oui c'est
bien plus agréable maintenant que quand
il y a du monde
en plus on a l'impression qu'ils se
battent pour avoir toujours la meilleure
place
aujourd'hui tu as pas besoin de te
battre je pense que la mairie devrait
apprendre à restreindre davantage
l'entrée aux touristes et laisser les
parcs dont nous profitons tous depuis
que nous sommes petits pour les
barcelonais
il n'y a que la partie du haut du parc
qui est gratuite habituellement mais là
où nous sommes maintenant il faut payer
normalement il faut payer pour entrer
c'est juste pour les touristes pas pour
les gens d'ici depuis plusieurs années
le tourisme de masse inquiète les
barcelonais et suscite l'hostilité de
certains habitants plusieurs
manifestations ont déjà eu lieu pour
dénoncer les incivilités des visiteurs
et une municipalité qui favorise le
bien-être des touristes au détriment de
ses habitants pilier de l'économie
locale le secteur touristique représente
12 % de l'économie catalane
problème depuis le 15 mars le tourisme
est au point mort alors pour tenter de
sauver la saison estivale le premier
ministre espagnol pedro sanchez a
décrété samedi la réouverture des
frontières dès le mois de juillet pour
accueillir les touristes étrangers
et puis en italie des manifestations à
milan hier manifestation des gilets
oranges pour demander la démission du
gouvernement
des centaines de personnes vous voyez se
sont rassemblés
et pour appeler à la levée des
restrictions sanitaires ils réclament
notamment la possibilité de sortir du
territoire écouter le peuple italien n'a
pas peur le peuple italien a le désir de
se racheter
[Musique]
le président de la république le chef du
gouvernement les membres du parlement
tous sont peu notre service c'est la fin
d'un gouvernement composé de gens
arrogants
c'est la fin de seconde et puis en
israël l'esplanade des mosquées à
jérusalem a rouvert aux fidèles c'est le
troisième lieu saint de l'islam et de
nombreux fidèles donc vous voyez masqués
ont pu de nouveau y venir pour la prière
le site avait été fermé à la mi mars par
les autorités religieuses
la pandémie a fait 284 morts en israël
et 3 seulement dans les territoires
palestiniens
des nouvelles de l'espace à présent avec
l'arrivée de la fusée falcon 9 à la
station internationale spatiale arrimage
réussi à 16h22 exactement après 18
heures de vol à 28 milles kilomètres
heure autour de la terre les deux
astronautes américain bob behnken et
doug hurley ont donc pu rejoindre la
station spatiale internationale ils ont
même pu pénétrer à l'intérieur à 7
heures et il devrait y rester jusqu'à
début août
voyez l'analyse de cet événement
historique par le spationaute français
michel tonini
on n'aura pas le bilan complet de cette
mission tant que l'atterrissage n'a pas
été fait de façon complète et en
sécurité à l'avs a dit qu' elle voulait
laisser ses vols en orbite basse ont
causé des commercial en disant que mais
vraiment une basse ont été réalisés par
la nasa depuis de nombreuses années avec
succès donc l inverse de libérer du pit
cher en laissant l'accès à la 8e place
où l'on apprécié privé et en
s'autorisant la nasa à faire les
missions qui sont plus complexes en
mission pour aller sur la lune ou sur
mars ou sur des astéroïdes
donc c'est une répartition qui montre
clairement la volonté de la nasa de ce
faire de l'exploration spatiale en
dehors de leurs départs de leur deux
passes et
les soeurs de basse ou souhaitez
commercial ce qui fait aussi gagner de
l'argent est là la vallée qui donne
aussi un budget conséquent à la société
spe 6 et en russie n'est donc plus la
seule à envoyer des cosmonautes vers la
station spatiale internationale via sa
fusée soyouz qui part de baïkonour au
kazakhstan
tout le monde pourra profiter du succès
de cette mission space x selon l'agent
spatiale russe au russe roskosmos
écoutez cette version du vaisseau
spatial est très importante parce que
les gens ont volé sur un nouveau
vaisseau ce qui ouvre une nouvelle étape
du programme mondial de véhicules
spatiaux habités et de la station
spatiale internationale où ce vaisseau
s'est rendu car de nouvelles
possibilités de nouvelles réserves
apparaissent je suis convaincu que le
succès de cette mission nous donnera des
possibilités supplémentaires qui seront
bénéfiques à l'ensemble du programme
mondial et c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de votre fidélité sur notre
antenne on se retrouve dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
non
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur la rime paul
c'était vraiment le laboratoire volant
qui montrait que non seulement on
pouvait s'alimenter au solaire non plus
on pouvait être extrêmement efficients
sur le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes là du climat de
l'environnement il ya un état d'urgence
actuellement il est en état d'urgence
on est en train de détruire la
biodiversité s'accélère l'habitation ça
s'accélère de manière